I'm not afraid of death my spirit will
live on my soul will live on my physical
body belongs to dr. Spitzer this human
project was designed by the National
Library of Medicine we wanted to take
photographic slices through a person's
body and you can't photograph the inside
with visible light unless it's a cadaver
this is the most high quality imagery
taken of an entire human body
that exists Susan Potter had a newspaper
article to describe the visible human in
great detail and that made her want to
be part of this educational process for
medical students it's easy to write a
prescription it's easy to give an
injection there's more to it than that
and that is my project so discipline
human into putting information and
teaching to the entire healthcare
profession Sue's reveals a lot to me
about her life I was accused of keeping
her a lie just because she was living
for donating to be part of this project
now I've got to do what I said I would
do and that is virtualize is her because
that's what I'm committed to
[Music]
[Music]